[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hi.
And welcome back to The
Developer Show's coverage
at GDD India.
I'm Dan Galpin here
with Wayne Piekarski
to chat about the latest
from Android Things.
So what is Android Things, and
how does it relate to Android?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Well,
the thing with it
is it's just another flavor
of Android in the same way
that you've got Android
Wear or Android TV.
It's just another
version, except it's
designed for building IoT
devices and especially
devices without screens.
And you can embed it in
any kind of IoT application
in the same place that you
would have used something
else before.
So, yeah.
DAN GALPIN: So what
kind of hardware
does Android Things run on?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
So Android Things
runs on custom-made hardware.
So I've got a little
circuit board here.
So the circuit board is
based around a concept called
a system on a module, where
it's a small computing
module with the CPU, the
Wi-Fi, and the RAM on it.
And that's the core part
that we provide software for,
and everything else is
controllable by the developer.
So this board here
is a developer kit
which has USB, Ethernet,
and stuff like that.
But you wouldn't use all of
that in a production device.
So this is used for
making prototypes.
And then once
you're finished, you
design your own custom board.
And then you have
it manufactured
in large quantities.
And it's cheap and
affordable because it
has only the components
that you need.
DAN GALPIN: So what is the
system on module, or SOM,
and how does it
help IoT designers?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: The
thing with the SOM
is it's a common module
that Google supports.
So we provide the kernel,
the drivers, the libraries,
everything needed.
And you don't have to do
any of the source code
or anything like that.
So we provide binaries for that.
And then you can focus on
making your own application.
And because the SOM is
kind of a fixed design,
you don't have to worry
about it changing.
Everything's handled for you.
DAN GALPIN: So now where does
the Android Thing project
stand?
Can developers use it today?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
So right now, it's
a developer preview.
So you can use it for
making test devices
and trying out new ideas.
And we're hoping
that next year, we're
going to be going to the
full LTS release, which
stands for Long Term Support.
And that's going to be the
production version that you're
going to be able to make devices
and push updates out too.
And they're going to
be ready for consumers
to make really nice,
reliable products.
We have a really good
story around updates.
And our team makes
the security updates
and pushes them to the devices.
So it makes devices
that are really
secure that consumers
are going to be
able to have confidence in.
DAN GALPIN: That's great.
Now I know we recently announced
the winners of the Android
Things Hackster.io contest.
Now can you tell us
about some entries that
might have stood out to you?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
We had a whole bunch of
really cool submissions
to the Hackster contest.
It was actually really hard to
try to pick a winner for that.
There were three really
good entrants that
were awarded the prizes for it.
Actually one of my
favorites was one
where someone built a
newsreader where you can hold it
in your hands, and it was
like a Braille display,
where you could use
your hands to have
news articles read to you.
And I really think
with Android Things,
were going to open
up possibilities
to make cool devices that are
going to help people who might
not be able to type, or
might not be able to speak,
who might have vision problems
or something like that.
And so people are going to
be able to make cool devices.
And because they're
so easy to make,
it's going to be possible
to make more of them.
Right now making custom,
specialized devices
is very expensive.
And I think it's
really going to--
we call it democratizing
hardware development.
We want to be able to make it
so anyone can make hardware
in the same way that
anyone can make software.
DAN GALPIN: So I know you've
traveled the world introducing
developers to Android Things.
What has that been like?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
It's been really fun.
It's been great to sort of
come to events like GDD India.
We have a huge
Sandbox area there.
And we've had a ton of
people come up to us.
And they want to
know how to do things
or how to build certain--
they've got questions.
And it's really cool to really
come here and meet people.
There's only so much you can
do on social media or whatever.
So it's been really great
to meet people in person,
and spend time with
them, and find out
what they're working on.
DAN GALPIN: Now
you've actually done
Codelabs where you've introduced
people to Android Things.
What's that like?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: It's really fun
because we give these kits away
to everyone in the room.
And they open them up,
put them all together.
And some people have never done
hardware development before.
I mean a lot of
software developers,
they write software.
But then with the
kits, you realize
this is something you
can pull apart and play
with and experiment with.
It's kind of like playing
with toys when you're a child.
You can build things and
assemble it yourself.
So it's really fun to
watch people do that.
And they leave
the Codelab going,
wow, I can use the camera, run
TensorFlow on it, and use it.
And it works.
And now I can take it home
and build some cool project
that they're trying to work on.
So, yeah.
DAN GALPIN: Where can developers
go for more information
about Android Things?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
So the best place is the
Android developer site.
So developer.android.com/things.
And all of our documentation's
there, the set-up guides,
samples, and so forth.
And that's a really great way
to get started and sort of learn
more about Android Things.
DAN GALPIN: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Wayne,
for joining us today.
Now visit the description
below if you'd
like to find out how to get
started with your own Android
Things projects.
[MUSIC PLAYING]